what's going on guys my name is david
thomach and welcome back to the channel
right now in 2021 i'm a registered
architect in the state of western
australia
and today we're talking about the
process of hiring an architect
and getting your custom home or even
potentially commercial project
built and ready to move in
[Music]
so where does it all start well it
generally starts with an introduction
between yourself
and myself for example we start by
getting to know each other a little bit
and understanding the project what is
going on in your head
and what kind of realistic expectations
you might have about this project
we might start talking let's use this
example as a house
so it might be a house on a brand new
vacant block
we know that you want a specific set of
instructions for that house
potentially four bedrooms two bathrooms
keeping it simple
we might understand what kind of style
and feel you like for the house
and how you want it to go they're the
basics that we don't really have to
cover in this video it's kind of just
expected that that conversation is going
to occur
but from there most things are a mystery
to people they don't know the process
they don't know what happens
so generally what happens is you engage
an architect
through a formal contract agreement that
contract will outline a scope of
services
for that individual project for that
individual block
usually you cannot take a project away
to another block
even if they're identical without the
consent of the architect
so it's important that you get the block
and everything else absolutely correct
once a contract between yourself and
myself has been established
we then start actually working and doing
some documentation
so we begin with the sketch design phase
the sketch design phase is the very
start of the whole project
it's where we try and extrapolate our
understanding of your idea
you've told us one thing and we will
create whatever we can
based on the understanding of what
you've given us
we're trying to basically read your mind
at this point in time we're trying to
understand
what you're thinking and how you're
thinking to be able to best design
for you specifically nine times out of
ten it isn't always
perfect straight away because we're only
trying to read your mind we can't
actually read your mind
so what happens here is we come and sit
down with you for the first time
after about a week or so we then discuss
that project and that sketch design with
you
and understand what you like and what
you don't like about it so we can
continue on
with the project so once we've sat down
and discussed that first project
that first attempt from us we'll go back
and begin
developing that sketch design usually
there's either one or two more sketch
designs before we absolutely nail that
brief
and we get exactly what you're looking
for out of that architectural project
once we've completed sketch design we'll
move on to a phase called design
development
design development is where we really
start breaking down the project
and working through it in a more
architectural sense we now start
implementing the council policies the
government policies
and all the local regulations that might
affect this project we take this project
further
until the point where it's ready to
submit to council so
it gets more detailed it gets more
thought out it gets more planned out
and it gets a lot more documentation
behind it towards the end of design
development it's all about understanding
the project a little bit better and
understanding those council policies
so that when we submit to council there
isn't that many
external changes that need to happen
after you get a development approval
this project is usually still very
personal one-on-one with you
we walk you through this process we talk
about it we then generally
discuss and have many many meetings in
between that first sketch design where
it was a stab in the dark
to where we're ready to submit to
council to have a planning approval
so in australia this is considered a
development application where you're
looking to get a development
approval so that way you can actually go
and apply
for a building permit now when we've
submitted to council we can take up to
90 days and just sit there in the
council
yes we can continue to do work on this
project but it's completely up to you
sometimes clients want to push and get
projects done quicker
so we start working on what's called the
working drawings
the working drawing can either be
started once we get development approval
or they can be started simultaneously
once it's at council
it's completely up to you but the
working drawings is where we get down
into the technical details of the house
we start analyzing every connection
point every detail we start selecting
materials
we start selecting plumbing fixtures
taps toilets
showers shower heads and we just go
through the list one by one this is
where you really get involved and you
start to enjoy
and experience the process a lot more
this is where it's all about you it's
all about your selections
or alternatively you can hire an
architect as an interior designer as
well and they can complete that whole
fit out for you the working drawings are
usually a rather large set of documents
there's about 40 or 50 odd pages in
total just of documentation and drawing
there's potentially also another 100 200
300 pages depending on how big the
project is
of actual specifications of everything
that you've selected to go in this house
once this working drawings is completed
we're ready to send it out for tender
now what tender means is we can either
go out and select a number of builders
who would like to tender on this project
and give you their best price
or a number of builders can be invited
there's a whole series of different ways
the general consensus is that we're
going out to builders to be able to get
a quote back
for the project and for it to be very
competitive so you get the best price
possible the tender process is anywhere
from about four to five weeks depending
on how large the project is
it can span longer if it's a busy period
or an extremely large project the
builders will then come in with their
price
usually on the very last minute of the
very last day of the tender process
because they don't want their price to
be leaked to their competitors so
they're very secretive about it even if
they finish three weeks before once all
the tenders have come in we get you back
into the
boardroom usually and we sit down and
discuss
all of the tenders that have come back
in again nine times out of ten the
tenders come in within budget
because we're always budget checking and
budget controlling throughout the whole
project
it's our job to make sure we try and
stick to budget
even though sometimes we go over if that
does happen for example and we do go
over the budget
most of the time it's only five or ten
percent and most clients are okay with
that
if they aren't then we look at ways of
reducing the cost we either
take out some of the specifications pick
some cheaper items or we make the house
smaller
redesign or do whatever we can to bring
that price
and that whole project back into budget
the selection of the builder is then
considered the final point of the tender
process it isn't always
the cheapest builder because when you
review tenders there is
a lot of elements that could be missing
so the cheapest tenderer could be
cheaper
by fifty thousand dollars but they could
have missed some substantial elements in
the build
so the second cheapest builder who has
thoroughly done their research and knows
every bit of this house has potentially
priced it perfectly
whereas now you know that second
cheapest build-up is actually
really the cheapest build-up so the
tender process and
the tender results aren't always fair
and even towards the end
and the bottom line figure isn't always
what it appears to be at the end of the
day it is absolutely the client's choice
so it's your choice
to decide which builder you want to go
for if you want to go for the most
expensive
most premium builder out of all the
tenders who've been in that process
you are absolutely more than welcome to
we only provide recommendations and who
we believe has given the best price and
is the best suited for your project
so at this point in time we reach a fork
in the road it's up to the client to
decide if they want project management
or contract administration from the
architect
or if they wish to part ways usually
most people decide to part ways because
they like to be as heavily involved as
possible with their home
during the construction process now
obviously as an architect i
recommend against this for the simple
fact that you're a lot more emotionally
invested
than any architect who is project
managing your job
so it is our best interest to be able to
produce the best quality at the end of
the day
and make the best possible choices if
you decide to part ways with your
architect
the process has been fairly simple it
has been predominantly around designing
that perfect floor plan
and designing every single element for
you to be able to go out
to a build up with a full set of
documentation that they can build the
house from
if you decide on the other hand to stick
with your architect for the remaining
portion of your contract
well then the architect is very active
and constantly in communication with you
so the architect's role in the project
management or the contract
administration phase
is for them to be able to actually
mediate that process
and to be the middleman so the builder
will always come to the architect and
ask the architect all the questions
first
if the architect for example doesn't
know the question that's when it will be
relayed back to the client
however most of the time all the
questions are simply in the
documentation
that the builder is missed or it's
something that wasn't documented
entirely
for one reason or another and then the
architect can answer that
accordingly the architect usually
manages all the progress claims that
come in for the builder so every time
the builder claims
for a certain value of money the
architect goes out on site
assesses that claim to make sure it's
entirely accurate
and that all the works completed so far
are genuinely up to a high standard and
then they're able
to process that claim if a builder tries
to pull a wool over your eyes and claim
for something that hasn't been completed
well then as the architect as the
mediator you can easily reject that
claim and only pay for a certain portion
of the fees that have been actually
completed this is usually where clients
and builders get into arguments
because clients don't want to pay
something or the builder is trying to
force them to pay something and they
have no leg to stand on
whereas the architect is the mediator
they are the contract administrator
what they say goes if the architect says
no this hasn't been completed therefore
it is not being paid
that's it the client pays for only that
section that has been completed
however this works vice versa as well if
the client is complaining about
something that the builder is wanting to
charge them for
and you go in as the architect and
assess everything and
look at this claim and go well this is a
genuine claim
it needs to be paid for again that is
the final verdict
it's the final thing and the client has
to pay for whatever that architect
has provided that certificate for now
this goes on for the whole construction
process until we get to the very end
where the builder believes they've
reached practical completion practical
completion
is a term in the building industry where
the builder believes they have
reached a stage where the project is
practically complete
so it doesn't necessarily need to be 100
complete but it is
practically there a little scratch here
and there or a little dent that needs to
be fixed up
is definitely not considered as anything
major but no roof couple walls missing
no doors
kitchen not installed things like that
that are pretty major that wouldn't
allow you to move in properly
are not considered practically at this
point in time again we meet with the
builder on site who has your keys ready
to go
as the architect we walk through that
entire project
and look for any defects that the
builder may have missed
may have done incorrectly or anything
that we would consider a defect
defects can be anything from a scratch
on the wall to
actually something completely wrong on
the floor plan once the practical
completion stage has been reached and
this inspection has been completed the
client yourself
takes possession of the site it is your
site now you can
move in you can live in it you can do
whatever you like with that property
now at this point in time it is entirely
your project it is entirely your home
and we step away for approximately 12
months in 12 months time we will come
back
to that site and do a final inspection
it's 12 months generally speaking
because it allows for all four seasons
so if you're off project finish for
example at the end of winter
you'll make sure that you see the next
winter and experience if there's any
leaks
any floods or anything like that that
might occur the final inspection
is there for us again to investigate
that property to understand if anything
has gone wrong if any defects have
occurred
and if all the defects from the previous
inspection have been rectified
after this final inspection that is the
end of the journey with your architect
that is usually where your architect
parts ways and you say your goodbyes
most of the time when you build a home
with a client
and an architect the relationship
matures and you become friends at the
end of the day
so just because this is the end of your
professional relationship as
architecting client
doesn't always necessarily mean it's the
end of your relationship as friends now
the whole project is
very enjoyable and sometimes a little
bit stressful i won't lie to you
but that's why you have your architect
there by your side to help you
and guide you through the process it is
something that we absolutely love doing
we love creating we love seeing our
projects come to life
so if you are excited to start your
journey with an architect
make sure you do your homework on them
make sure you genuinely just enjoy them
as a person
because you're going to be spending a
lot of time with them over the next
couple of years
anyway that's all for me today guys
thanks so much for watching i hope you
enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you subscribe to
the channel down below this is still
a video in february so we are doing 28
videos
in 28 days usually it will be see you
next monday but because it is february
i'll see you tomorrow